it will take you live to Gallipoli the
Prince of Wales is speaking at a
commemoration event ablution
to join you in commemorating the gallant
individuals who fought so courageously
on this peninsula a century ago all
those who fought at Gallipoli with a
landing on or defending its shores
hailed from so many different nations
and people's from an almost infinite
variety of backgrounds and walks of life
and whilst our origins were diverse they
were all thrust into a very different
world than they would ever have known or
imagined before
indeed in 1915 both sides were united by
challenges that neither could escape the
devastating firepower of modern warfare
the ghastly diseases that added to the
death tolls the devastating summer heat
which brought plagues of insects and in
winter just before the battle ended the
biting cold that many wrote was worse
than the shelling itself on this
centenary occasion it seems to me that
we must remember the heroism and
humanity of those on both sides who had
to leave behind their families from
cities villages and farms around the
world to come here and confront the
horrors that they did and in an
appalling number of instances never to
see their loved ones again in May 1915 a
truce was arranged for one day to allow
both sides to bury
dead reflecting on this an Australian
private Henry Barnes said I sat on a
parapet and after a while walked over
and offered bully beef to one Turk he
smiled and seemed very pleased and
passed me a whole string of dates
private Barnes went on to talk about
Turkish soldiers in general the Turkish
soldier was very highly regarded by me
and all the men on our side I never
heard him to cried he was always a clean
fighter and one of the most courageous
men in the world another account of this
day came from Aubrey Herbert a British
officer who spoke Turkish he recalled
the words of a Turkish officer with whom
he spoke during the truce while the dead
were being recovered from the
battlefield at this spectacle even the
most gentle must feel savage and the
most savage must weep the battle at
Gallipoli is a striking reminder that
the Great War was truly a world war not
only because it's combatants were drawn
from so many different nations but also
because its effects were truly global
it destroyed old empires and created new
fissures just as he brought some
countries together in shared endeavors
and strengthened national identities
exemplified by the spirits and mate ship
of the Anzacs
who in fighting here at Gallipoli
contributed so profoundly to the proud
sense of nationhood of Australia and New
Zealand
perhaps today we should recognize that
over the past 70 years since the Second
World War many parts of the world have
enjoyed unprecedented periods of peace
and stability at the same time many
regions are torn by the most brutal of
conflicts say it seems to me that we
should remember with shame and profound
regret that despite the appalling
sacrifice made by so many in two world
wars intolerance combined with the
willingness to use the most barbaric
violence remain a persistent and
prevailing source of division and
conflict in today's world if I may dare
say so we all have a shared duty each in
our own way as individuals but also
together as leaders communities and
nations to find ways to overcome that
intolerance to fights against hatred and
Prejudice in pursuit of greater harmony
so that we can truly say we have honored
the sacrifice of all those who fought
and died on battlefields here at
Gallipoli and elsewhere